es ist soweit künstliche intelligenz ki
besiegt den menschen und das in immer
mehr bereichen ist ist schon ein wenig
beängstigend vielen mast und stephen
hawking hatten ja vorausgesagt dass uns
ki extrem gefährlich werden kann wo uns
bereits heute überlegen ist jetzt in
klicks und science fiction herzlich
willkommen und vielen dank für den
themenvorschlag über whatsapp und jetzt
erstmal eine kleine sensation vor zehn
jahren ende september 2008 haben
wirklich zum gestartet und heute starten
wir wieder clixoom auf englisch ab
sofort gibt es einen zweiten kanal mit
den besten und aktuellen science fiction
videos auf englisch wer also lieber
englische videos sieht oder englisch
lernen will
das geht ab sofort auf klicks um
science-fiction auf englisch ihr gelangt
hier über die infoguard zum kanal das
erste video ist bereits veröffentlicht
und heute abend um 18 uhr kommt ein
video dass es noch nicht auf dem
deutschen kanal gibt also direkt
abonnieren um nichts mehr zu verpassen
erst kürzlich im juli 2018 hat google
verkündet dass die von dem unternehmen
entwickelte künstliche intelligenz
menschliche spieler in einem ego shooter
game besiegt und das sehr zuverlässig
doch das ist nicht der einzige bereich
unseres lebens in dem neuronale netze
uns menschen mittlerweile überlegen sind
künstliche intelligenz zum beispiel die
ein falsches von einem echten lächeln
unterscheiden kann oder aber eine ki die
uns menschen demnächst von allen
möglichen krankheiten height 100 für die
küken und dabei teamplayer sein google
sky heißt vor gewinn ftd und bringt uns
in sachen gaming echt zum staunen die
software kann mit menschen aber auch mit
anderen maschinen zusammenarbeiten und
sich auf bestimmte spielweisen
einstellen und eben auch gewinnen
konkret geht es um den modus capture the
flag des shooter games quake 3 arena bei
dem die fahne des gegners zur eigenen
basis gebracht werden muss diesen erfolg
von fd dario hat jetzt das
entwicklerteam verkündet etwa 450.000
simulierten partien hat die ki gespielt
und so dazugelernt stichwort die
learning sowohl was das teamwork als
auch die spielmechanik angeht und das
game ist
60 nur ein wenig abgeändert vom original
die grafik ist etwas simpler gestaltet
und statt echten modellen gibt es
beispielsweise kugeln dann ist die ki in
einem turnier gegen 40 spieler
angetreten in einem team aus
ausschließlich maschinellen spielern hat
sie jedes spiel gegen menschen gewonnen
jedes spiel und auch ihre pfote gegen
ein gemischtes team also aus mensch und
maschine war mit 95 prozent mehr als
beachtlich überrascht waren die
entwickler von ft damit dass sie selbst
taktiken angewandt hatte die auch echte
gamer also menschen nutzen wie
beispielsweise ablenkungsmanöver oder
das verteidigen der eigenen basis andere
forschungsteams sind gerade dabei
computern das pokern beizubringen und
tatsächlich sind einige programme auch
schon in der lage zu bleiben zwei zu
null für die ki menschliche emotionen
erkennen egal ob überraschung trauer
ekel wut oder freude all diese
gefühlsregungen kann dass die learning
system der amerikanischen firma
effektiver korrekt zuordnen und deuten
dazu hatten ihm seine entwickler und
entwicklerinnen videos von menschen in
75 ländern vorgespielt die genau diese
emotionen zeigen und sich weltweit
gleich in den gesichtern spiegeln egal
woher die menschen kommen wie alt sie
sind oder welches geschlecht sie haben
die so entwickelte kai ist mittlerweile
schneller und auch genauer als die
meisten menschen sie kann sogar ein
echtes von einem falschen lächeln
unterscheiden das talent der ki soll
demnächst übrigens auch im
straßenverkehr eingesetzt werden das
system hat dann die aufgabe den
autofahrer oder die autofahrerin vor der
fahrt abzuchecken ob das emotionale
gleichgewicht überhaupt zum autofahren
geeignet ist denn wer wütend oder
aufregt ist wird schneller zum risiko im
straßenverkehr die mimik des fahrers
oder der fahrerin soll über eine kamera
analysiert werden auch wenn sie oder er
zu viel getrunken hat vor freude aus dem
häuschen ist oder aber immer wieder das
smartphone am steuer benutzt dann wird
das von der ki offengelegt 3 zu 0 für
die caps spielen und krankheiten
diagnostizieren
darüber haben wir hier ja schon öfter
berichtet die blondine kann ärzteteams
sehr effektiv unterstützen
beispielsweise können die algorithmen
lernen gesunde zellen von krebszellen zu
unterscheiden indem sie nach
verdächtigen merkmalen suchen zudem kann
die aber auch nach wirkstoffen und
medikamenten cocktail suchen
die individuell für jeden patienten und
jede patientin am passendsten sind dazu
ein paar konkrete beispiele
google möchte beispielsweise mit hilfe
von software depressionen heilen und
herzinfarkte mit hilfe künstlicher
nano-partikel voraussagen das projekt
heißt hannover die idee dahinter
computer sollen sich zunächst einmal das
komplette medizinische wissen aneignen
heißt also studien lesen und verstehen
millionen von artikeln sind verfügbar
und täglich kommen neue erkenntnisse
hinzu wie soll da ein mensch mit kommen
das ist einfach unmöglich aber kein
großes problem für maschinen sie sollen
ärzteteams in zukunft dann dabei
unterstützen personalisierte
behandlungsmethoden zu finden
ibm hat eine ki entwickelt die die dna
sequenzierung eines gehirntumors
schneller und zuverlässiger analysiert
hat als das gesamte team der
menschlichen experten und expertinnen 40
für die juristische klauseln analysieren
bei der studie der plattform logix ging
es um die analyse der geheimhaltung
verträge großer 25 top anwälte traten
gegen den algorithmus an und die ki
gewann haushoch das ziel war es fünf
verträge innerhalb von vier stunden zu
analysieren und 30 rechtliche probleme
zu identifizieren
die ki hat für fünf verträge nur rund 25
sekunden gebraucht die anwälte
benötigten durchschnittlich 92 minuten
zudem war die arbeit die ihn noch
sorgfältiger als sie der menschlichen
anwälte ihre genauigkeit lag bei 94
prozent die ihrer menschlichen
konkurrenz bei 85 prozent bei einem
vertrag kamen der beste der anwälte auf
97 aber auch hier war die kab st sie
erlangte eine hundertprozentige
genauigkeit 15 neu für die wartung von
maschinen ja den letzten punkt den gibt
es im duell mensch gegen künstliche
intelligenz bei der wartung von
maschinen auch hier geht es um die
analyse einer gigantischen datenflut die
neuronale netze deutlich schneller und
zuverlässiger analysieren können als wir
menschen windturbinen beispielsweise
produzieren pro tag hunderte gigabyte
daten und die ki lernt diese zu
interpretieren also bei windrädern ist
das der fall
die gehen ja immer wieder kaputt und die
ständig zu analysieren das kann am
besten gibt es nämlich eine
ungewöhnliche schwingung oder muss in
der nächsten
zeit eine wartung durchgeführt werden so
können mögliche beschädigungen schon
wochen vorausgesehen werden und es kommt
zu weniger oder im besten fall sogar
keinem ausfall der turbinen mehr eine
leistung die menschen einfach nicht
erbringen können
und jetzt brauche ich eure unterstützung
lasst uns den englischen kanal so
richtig pushen kriegt also hier drauf
abonniert live kommentiert und haut
ordentlich auf die genau auf die glocke
erzählt euren englischsprachigen science
freundin von uns austauschschülern oder
allen die ihr englisches vokabular ein
bisschen verbessern wollen teilt das
ganze bis der arzt kommt und wir sehen
uns um 18 uhr
dort auf dem kanal für ein brandneues
video dass es im deutschen noch nicht
gab und hier geht es weiter mit dem
ersten englischen video also unbedingt
drauf klicken
das zeigen feel like stay tuned csu